and I am a United Methodist pastor I'm
or Dave in the United Methodist Church
and I am a lead pastor of Costa Mesa
First United Methodist or first United
I'm also an author and a speaker and I'm
Leon Brown I am associate pastor I saw
them in temples in Pittsburg California
and my question we have first is from a
hand eh and I hope that's how we our
biggest fear by the way is getting your
name wrong how did you become a preacher
or a pastor say always had is calling on
my life since I was a young man probably
five years old just in the bathroom by
myself with a little orange Bible
reading as I progressed through life
went to high school about 11th grade I
septum I'll call and I preached my very
first sermon ever and that's how my
journey started in eleventh grade I got
the call what about you I was actually I
had no intention of being a pastor I was
studying to be but didn't know what I
wanted me so I was that need to be a
doctor is like a fullback acting and
also hard which makes their sense when I
was in college and then I realized even
though it's part of a sorority and I was
part of playing a lot of sports and I
spending most of my extra time with the
kids that I was volunteering with as a
youth pastor never thought I would be a
preacher went to seminary went to a
great seminary called Duke in North
Carolina studied religion and never
thought I would be a preacher but what
happened is more and more preach the
more and more I realized that was sort
of my calling and other people saw that
in me so I got where Dave is United
Methodist clergy remember that
I got it all right our first step
question is what does it mean to be
saved what I was taught is John 3:16 for
God so loved the world that He gave His
only begotten Son whoever shall be
leaving that shedding that perish but
have eternal life which means if you die
you know where you going we was taught
you go into heaven
you're gonna spend eternity with Jesus
Christ our Lord and Savior that's what
it means is to be secure and 1/2 the
light to know that we have somewhere to
go
and so that's a tough question actually
because when you talk about saved you're
wondering like what does it mean to be
saved in the moment what does it mean to
believe a lot of people have what's
called like the believers prayer so but
that's a belief an idea well I'm sure
we'll talk later about heaven and hell
but a lot of people wonder if it's
sparing you from something but I think
when I think about what does it mean to
be saved I think about actually here and
today and for me my faith means that I
have something to lean into I have
something that brings me joy I have this
sense of being saved from a lot of the
difficult things and also being present
to the world in a different way so
that's what took me means yeah it
doesn't necessarily mean a lot of people
think it's like I get out of hell free
card yeah that's how I look at the idea
of being saved so I think you're kind of
you kind of get saved every day in a
different way
all right so now why are there so many
denominations which is funny because him
and I are in two different denominations
so there is the answer we talked earlier
and I said I would be the keeper of the
nerd and
why are there so many denominations well
denominations started a long time ago
and there's lots of different reasons I
mean the overall answer is that people
are really different than they see
things that really you and I see things
really differently and so people tend to
stick around people that are similar to
them or believe similarly to them if you
want to talk about why we have like
Catholicism and why have Protestantism
so most churches that are not Catholic
or Protestant if you're Christian and
that is really because of one word and
the word is s mmm and if this is my body
which in Greek is s which it means so
when Christ said this is my body some
people mint thought that meant like
literally the Communion turns into
Christ actual body other people thought
that it meant that this was you know
just a representation of us so that's
sort of started the whole thing but then
there's all different reasons why we
split up and why people sometimes can't
get along um and it's a different way
that people look at the Bible some
people take word-for-word literally some
of us contextualize it so there's all
different denominations for those
reasons and truthfully people can't seem
to get along and she's gonna be division
which is sad but it's reality in his
reality all right our women allowed to
preach will in mark chapter 16 I'm
hearing out on 9 do 10 when Jesus
actually rose and was coming from the
temple the first person was there was
Mary Magdalene and he told her to go out
and tell the people that he was risen
and if you look at that scripture in
that takes it shows you that she's
preaching the good news of our Lord and
Savior did die but yet he got up again
and that was a woman that went out and
share that word so I think just with
that Scripture it's evidence that women
have been preaching since the Lord had
risen so my answer is yes women can I
like you Leon
actually Paul who said women couldn't
preach because there is verses that say
you women be silent and I do not permit
you women to teach over men but it's
actually if you look at it and if you
look at the original language it's
talking to a specific group of women
that were spreading rumors so again it's
how you look at the Bible and that's how
people get to different understandings
of things so can women preach absolutely
Jews and I think God would be wasteful
if only using half of the people to
bring the good news so I'm glad that you
agree with me then the church is filled
up with really women yeah there's a lot
of women so I'll hold
very good priests I know I think it's
really interesting - usually people who
are against women preaching or like but
you can teach kids and it's Kali is what
I'm preaching I'm doing the same thing
it is the same thing and once you know
kids grow up so you're kind of doing the
main thing exactly are women allowed to
preach in my denomination yes and even
encouraged exactly hey here we go it's
sex before it merits a sin I believe it
is I believe I was taught that sex
before marriage is a sin and then I'm
John 3 4 through 10 he says it's no one
who abides and him keeps on sinning no
one who keeps on sinning has either seen
him or know him for their self and I
just believe that's an intimate that's
very something you should hold on to a
till your husband finds you that is
something that got placed inside of you
that it shouldn't just be spreaded
throughout the world with just everyone
you have to wait to that special someone
find you and I do believe it's a sin
that's what I was taught I mean I think
if you look at it though it's really the
question is what is sin sin is kind of
the idea of something that separates us
from God or something that creates a
chasm sex before marriage a sin I'm
gonna say it depends because it's kind
of like Euphemia flesh and anything when
you don't follow the spirit and you
listen to your flesh the flesh separated
us from God and again where did this
idea that thankful for mayor
i'ma send a lot of people use scripture
as the idea but if you're looking at a
document that is so old and has like
marriage was an entirely different
entity back then in fact it really is
usually sex before marriage is really
talking about the idea that when you're
having sex before marriage there's the
potential of having a kid and having a
kid met responsibility and usually what
you find is the sin part of it is not
taking care of those that you have
created not taking care of women you
know we were we were more like property
right and so to have sex with a woman
before marriage would have meant that
she can have a kid and then you're not
taking care of them and so again it's
just an entirely different culture an
entirely different time I mean like 2019
think about it
if you lay down I'm not getting another
person and y'all just get an intimate
and you haven't six and then the baby is
born why I come from a lot of men
running for defendant I know you're not
taking care then see why because they
just wanted to hit in the crib all they
wanted was to get one off and now you're
stuck with a child and if he would have
just preserved yourself and kept
yourself you would have saved yourself a
lot of headache and that's the
generation we live in now you don't care
about actually building a family you
just want to get one or if you want to
pleasure yourself and it caused a lot of
pain and travel the tribulations a long
a mine I think it's tough though because
you can't just make I think making a
hard and fast rule is this right is this
wrong the truth of the matter is when it
come down to it and looking at sort of
the sexual ethic you have are you taking
advantage of people all sexual and
things within scripture or even within
Christianity really comes down should
come down to sort of are you caring for
the other and so sex for marriage is a
tough question because most people
aren't getting married till they're 30
so what does that mean people don't even
become adults technically Phil they're
25 so if we're talking about using a
scripture to represent what was
happening when people were coming of age
dying much younger I would be dead
statistically the idea of sex before
marriage it's a tough question but I
think it really comes down to you what
is your sexual ethic how are you caring
for the other person are you prepared to
raise a child if if sex is if that's
what sex can create and that's usually
when are you ready to get a disease to
gain its trophies everything else can I
mean yes so there's that question I want
to just keep giving yourself away body
can't go on like toxic understanding
that somehow people are damaged and I
think we have to watch out when we talk
about people who have had premarital sex
if there's you know that these people
are damaged or harmed and and oftentimes
sex can be again about dominance and
about control and I just think we have
to be careful when we make these rules
as if someone who has gone through
something traumatic it's all of a sudden
sinful and I think oftentimes that
language comes out of the Christian
Church so sex before marriage is sin I'm
gonna go in it depends i'ma say it is
sadly on it it is grace and mercy that's
why let's move on he's drinking a sin
Paul told Timothy stop drinking water
stop drinking water and drink the wine
to make it something feel better so I
think it's not a sin Jesus turned water
into wine I think this is all about how
you can take it if you're just you know
casually drinking and having a good time
okay but once you start overdoing it
once you start turning to the bottle to
get that that creep fixed like man I'm
going do it this is only my only escape
it's like no once the alcohol become
your way out that's when I believe it's
a problem because now you put in
for god I think it's a it's the same
thing as I said earlier I think is
drinking of sin I'm gonna say it depends
I think drinking when it is drinking in
moderation when it's enjoyable when you
are having fun when it's something that
isn't causing you to escape from your
own life or not be present to other
people to be harmful of other people I
think that's when it is a sin I think
you know when we talk about the safety
of others and yourself that's when it
becomes sinful and so it's that idea of
separating hey what's the influence
you're under right you know so that's a
good question
all right so now we have ones with
people's names so Megan Pridemore does
ask do you support LGBT plus people so
LGBTQIA people so go ahead of course
we're all God's people God love us in
spite of our sins we all have sinned and
fallen short of his glory and that's in
the word it doesn't matter what you
struggle with it's still a shrill and
Sanderson I don't care if you're gay I
don't care if you kill someone you used
to be a prostitute you sold drugs God
love us in spite of all our flaws and
wrongdoing and if a God can love us and
look past if God can love me in spite of
everything I've done in my life how is
it that I can love my brother how is it
that I can't love a person who's gay or
lesbian I love them the same you may not
agree with the sin but you still love
the sinner
all right comes down to the question is
it it's been really so for my belief I
actually do support LGBTQ I some of the
best people in my church Ammar the truth
of the matter is I don't see it as a sin
and my denomination is even splitting
over or not splitting over that but I'm
split in that idea more that more
commerce kind of figure out if we can
remain together over this but for me as
I look at Scripture and I look at
scripture about LGBTQIA issues again sex
was not the same thing and when we talk
about
manling with another man it was about
power you know the sin of sodom and
gomorrah is really about sexual abuse
there's this horrible story of not
caring for the other and it's actually
quite a powerful story about rape and we
look at this and we think so what is
LGBTQIA it's not the same thing then if
we're talking about healthy
relationships that are bringing about
goodness in the world and creating
sometimes even more healthy situations
than for me I don't think it's a sin and
I also do I support LGBTQIA I do
absolutely and so for me I don't even
use a language of sin or or you know I
agree with you I do think that all of us
well short of the glory of God all of us
are making mistakes all the time but for
me that's not one of those things I
consider a mistake that's for me all
right Sarah how do I stop being sad I
want a joy of the Lord
there's your strength the joy of the
Lord
when you look back over your life and
you see all the things that you've been
do what I like to tell people is if God
did it before he'll do it again
oftentimes we get to a place where we
feel like healing nothing we feel like
going to talent in and it's because the
obstacles look so big but oftentimes
we're looking at the problem we're not
looking at the one that had the solution
how I get through from shaking myself
off and not being sad is I don't worry
about things that's out of my control if
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen if
it's meant to be it's gonna be like God
is the author and finisher of our faith
and what that means is if there's gonna
work is going to if it's not it's not so
how do I pull myself out that satisfy
I'll reflect back and I know God brought
me out of this thing before
you know I just like you know how do I
stop being inside I think is also a
tough question because it depends if
you've got something like depression or
a difficult thing like that you
literally can't I think the way that you
look at it it's definitely looking back
and saying where are those places where
I have found encouragement and I found
peace and who are the people that I can
tell I'm sad I think sometimes we live
in a in a generation that's so connected
but so disconnected and so how do I stop
being sad for me the answer is always I
surround myself with people who can
encourage me and here can be positive
because it's not always easy to pull
yourself out of it and I think God is
with us for sure but I think there are
also people who can be placed in your
life to help you through those tough
times you can sometimes we do want to
isolate ourselves and that is you know
sometimes isolation can be good but
sometimes it can be bad cuz it make you
slip into depression even deeper so I
agree get around people tool that can
uplift your spirits and pull you up
there yeah it's a tough question and it
depends on what's causing you to be sad
so stare out I hope you figure it out
you got it yes that's right all right
Devon W wants to know are you a virgin
well I have a three-year-old daughter
Mary going on five years nowhere near
verse well you could have been like the
second happening though so that's a
tough question for me and I just earlier
said that
premarital sex for me do I think it's a
sin and I said sometimes and actually a
lot of times I think it is but so am i
virgin so when I got ordained I promise
to remain celibate outside of marriage
that's one of those things that we
promise and so I actually am which is
often very shocking for people and
shocking for me if I'm honest I know I
haven't gotten
all right Daisy French wants to know why
is abortion so wrong I believe this
because children are a gift from God and
I understand everybody circumstances are
different maybe you know a person was
ready and they got pregnant or maybe you
just young you're 13 you're scared you
don't know what to do this is very
sensitive I think how it can become
wrong is because God placed it in you
then you should birth it's a gift from
God and I think that's where it kind of
that's that PN line because they see
each other God I don't want this gift
but something or you is this from God if
I was raped and got pregnant so Daisy I
really don't have a solid answer for you
so easy why is abortion Saranga that
depends on who you're talking to and if
people think that abortion is is really
wrong so for for me and again I know
have lots of brothers and sisters who
don't think the same way I do I think
that there are circumstances and
instances where abortion is it is the
only way out whether it's for folks who
have illness and all that sort of stuff
sometimes the loss of the child is a
possibility there's all kinds of
situations I'm again gonna go back and I
hope it doesn't sound like a huge
cop-out but I think a lot of things are
situational and every time we try to put
a hard and fast rule on something we're
really just kind of forgetting that
there's an ethic around this as often
times people to get the most mad about
abortion being wrong are the people who
support the death penalty and so they
say life is life is life and yet when
that when that thing happens or don't
support taking care of kids who are born
without the you know financial means
they're not taking care of people so for
me I think abortion is one of those
tricky things that really comes down to
you who you are and what's going on in
your situation and so when you ask that
question I think it's a it's a pretty
loaded question because there are lots
of people who have
lots of things that happen with people
and honestly I so many about so many
opinions on these things and I feel like
until you have had to sit with people
who have gone through these things that
horrific different situation
circumstance and so it's kind of you
know just depend on a person yeah and so
I know I hate I feel like that was a
little bit of a cop-out but okay okay
this looks fine
go for it was twice twice way west I
don't know what is your opinion all
masturbation is it a senior to me
you shouldn't masturbate that's my
answer
[Laughter]
what do you mean like how people do that
like what do you mean what is your
opinion on masturbation is it a sin okay
first of all let's get to the history of
why people have always said it was the
same we were talking earlier that I'll
give the nerdy answer and yes you'll get
this straight up answer so a lot of that
comes from in Scripture there are
stories of people spreading their seed
and doing so I'm no graphic spreading
their seed in ways that do not produce
children at the time we're talking about
an oppressed people who are trying to
have their population grow so that
they're able to overcome oppression
they're able to face their enemies again
the Bible is written by a lot of times
the press people going through a lot and
so the idea was that if you were
masturbating and wasting reseed that
that was the sin but I think nowadays
you have pornography okay and the Word
of God speak about being lustful when
you're masturbating nowadays you're have
you have access on your phone you're
looking at a man in the female or
whatever your purpose is and you're
getting one off to that person you are
lessening to be intimate with that
female or whatever you prefer I think
that's when the sin come in because your
lustful you wish you had that person you
masturbate and then you think no need
[Applause]
and I think that's where the scene come
in you watching somebody you listen at
the Dillman to me that's the same again
I think it's all about the idea of you
know are we being helpful is this a good
thing is a helpful thing is this a
healthy thing and so I can I think like
in the morning you say that what you
doin tics and you don't get over pie you
know sex is this amazing thing and even
our ability to experience pleasure is
incredible right it's sacred
you know we joke around about a lot of
it and it makes us uncomfortable
sometimes to talk about it in our
culture but the truth of the matter is
it is the sacred thing that we can have
this experience of utter joy and so I
think again the answer is depends are
you are you objectifying someone are you
you know these are the different answers
because if you if you answer straight up
yes
then what about men who donate sperm
because that is done through a
masturbation yes this soon oh well now
we're onto something else
all right the next question Hayley
series is teen pregnancy okay
well according to the Bible yes because
Mary was a teenager but also other
answers so you go first I'm your answer
on that one I mean I believe if you're
married okay but like this one is
circumstance what happened how did you
be pregnant are you married what I want
my daughter to be present
[Laughter]
it's teen pregnancy okay I think the
answer is yes is it but our is it what
you believe are you Mary
what solace your definition of okay like
it happens is our body starts to be able
to do that now do I always think it's
okay
no because oftentimes teen pregnancy is
because someone has been taken advantage
of and there's also or someone you know
there's all kinds of circumstances and
world cultures and things where young
women don't have options and choices and
so teens pregnancy can both be okay and
not okay you know my friends were
married at 19 and fragment and so those
are still teenagers all right all right
moody teenager 13 these names are great
by the way if someone kills my whole
family do I still have to love them as
my neighbor and what if they actually
are my neighbor this I feel like we need
to call somebody this number he said
this is what makes me nervous what do i
do then so if someone kills your whole
family this is a question on forgiveness
I think when I get to the bottom of this
for moody teenager 13 if you're maybe
teenager 13 neighbor I'd sleeping when I
open go ahead what do you think well if
someone killed my whole family if I can
be transparent and honest I belong
vengeance I will be hurt I will be upset
but looking at things in the spiritual
eye I was shown mercy I was show grace
because I know that's what God want me
to do
in spite of what they done i'ma still
love my neighbor
well I forget what they did to me know
what I get close to that first I allow
them to get close to me again
absolutely not will it take time for me
to heal from this of course because we
are human we have emotions we feel
Payne but I would still love doing
because this commanded from God and how
can I say I love God which I never seen
and hate my brother well I see everyday
it's really a beautiful because I think
that says the heart of the matter is
getting down to what is forgiveness and
what does it look like and I think the
most compelling stories we ever hear are
the people who do forgive you know I
think about the Amish community that
forgiving forgave the man who who killed
all those children I think we are in the
moment when we can murder anyone we've
lost our humanity right humans really
aren't kind of made kill each other and
so it's this question of can I love
someone and I believe it God's presence
for me the divine presence isn't in
everyone and so how do I love someone
even when they've wronged me to the
point of this and the truth is um it's
hard it is what do i do then I think you
really reach into you what does it mean
to be human and what does it mean to see
the divine and other people and so I
think forgiveness is one of the things
that lets me know that God is real good
when I see those moments where people
are able to forgive people who have
damaged them beyond belief and I show
the same you have to show the same mercy
that you were want God to show to you
and I know that's easier said and done
but it's real because you can be so hurt
I'd be transparent again my father my
own life he wasn't there and I was so
hurt by him not being in my life to the
point where I got over now but my own
daughter it was kind of like I don't
want you to come around I don't think he
deserved to meet my daughter knowing my
wife he wasn't there for me but I wasn't
doing nothing but causing myself to hurt
I was reliving those years where I was a
child crying in the bathroom looking
myself in the mirror and wondering why I
wasn't good enough it wasn't a - I
forgave my father that I was able to be
a better father to my daughter I was
able to say okay you know what
he wasn't there but I'm here for my baby
he had a hole on me because what I
thought he should've known a forgiveness
hard and I think it's like the idea of
like obviously the extremum did they
kill your whole family like I think we
have to talk about how it really is a
hard thing to do as a human to forgive
someone for whatever it might be and I
think that it how do you do it what do I
be then the answer is that you're gonna
have to lean into being around people
who can help you get to that place I
don't think you want to rush it there's
nothing you think on of you yeah
forgiveness is is cheat certs own it is
really cheap if you if you just do it
out of the blue and for for no reason it
has to be a real thing and the real
forgiveness is the kind that takes time
okay this next one is Mayor Jam we're
gonna say Miriam Miriam Miriam what what
do you think of the church is it
necessary to be in one how the churches
created their own culture church culture
are they is that healthy or unhealthy
what a word of god say you should
separate your cell phone other
worshippers I believe the church is
necessary to come in with other
believers because she gave me strength
important to me I made me to pour back
into you verses if I'm just at home on
Sundays or what every day you choose to
worship I'm kind of missing it because
there's only so much encouraging you can
do for yourself so I feel like you
should get around other believers
because the hill who builds you love
yeah interesting because I think church
is a hard question so the first question
part of it is what do you think of it
church and the truth is is a church can
be great it can be a really healthy
place aquarium place a growth right or
it can be really damaging place in boxes
in place so the community that I'm in
right now gives me a lot of hope from
what churches I have lots of friends who
are amazing Christians you aren't a part
of a church I think you're right that
you're missing out on it it's kind of
like what you give in to it you get out
of it I think that there are seasons
when people Church is not the healthiest
thing for them and I
it's okay to step outside yeah and I
also think like me and what I actually
do for a living also like I am the
church we auditors like I have Church
inside of a person I have Church inside
of ourselves so my boys come around who
smoke who drink they don't go to a
regular Church but when they see me they
ask what's the word and I give them
exactly what they need they may never
set foot inside the church but think
about those people who encountered Jesus
that he was walking they didn't go to
the City of God they happen to see Jesus
coming past and Jesus was able to give
them exactly what they needed right then
and there and sometime that's what we
have to do for someone that may never
come to the church all it take is one
word from God to heal and save someone
and we always have to be ready to give
that word to someone that may never set
foot inside the Lord's house yeah I
think that's the interesting thing is
the idea of how did like good Jesus
go to church and the answer was nobody
was involved in a synagogue but as he
himself moved throughout the world he he
did have people that traveled with him
and those people were sort of like his
church or as ecclesia who's gathered
community and so I think it's important
that people around you that are helping
you ask the tough questions that are
being present to it do I think that this
church culture that's being created is
healthy the answer is no I think they're
for me this awkward the separation
between sacred and secular where people
are that that's bad because it's secular
misses out on I think that God is in and
through all things and so when we talk
about unhealthy Christian culture I
think there's some really there's a lot
of them just you know patriarchy
misogyny that comes from church culture
that really isn't from the stories of
Jesus and isn't from the Bible but it's
this thing that has been created
no way and made yeah and some of the the
very things that we know are the Heart
of Jesus when we see them being interact
like just out there in the world I mean
he said that this is Christianity that's
when church culture has become toxic I
mean and even the fact that it's so
sellable or you know that kind of thing
I think Jesus shakes his head at some of
that stuff so all right Ashlee just ask
can i baptize my dog my baby girl
baptize all her dolls and her doll so
you can I think the question really is
can actually baptizing I haven't really
good friend whose husband is an atheist
and she always said she wants me to trip
and spill water on his head you know
that that's kind of like why are you
baptizing you're done you're gonna go to
heaven I don't mean personally I
personally do tenor you are going to
heaven to me as I look at my dog who is
like to me the manifestation of the love
of God I mean he is taught me so much
about what it means to actually be a
person and so I I think baptizing your
dog is not a great idea that depends on
your theology of baptism which means
what do you do you think someone has to
be baptized do you think in order to go
to heaven you have to you have two heads
and say that question is very layered
it'd be funny I'm not worried about my
dog making each other yeah you're not
gonna miss your dog all right
uh-huh Dede 23 do you smoke weed is it a
sin
I used to blow it now what turned my
life around
was it a saying I don't think so well so
I do not totally but that's not a
judgment call I don't think it's a sin
and no I do not smoke weed that's just
because I don't that's not any judgment
cop but I used to so I know about it but
I think you can't actually be I mean
we're discovering that it's really
helpful if first folks you have issues
like epilepsy
you know the amazing thing that's
happening when we're just coming more
and more about we by the way this is
being filmed in California or what we're
saying is not Alicia and we know there's
going to be people church bishops and
all that that don't agree with where
you're going bishops I heard it nothing
wrong so I believe we know is gonna be
that home here about I don't think but
that's just I don't I'm gonna see it as
one we talked before we had sorry saving
this that we want to take that's how you
know home recording this I don't know
streaming this is that we want to be
honest with people but we know that we
have bosses so Frogger Burke great name
how do I grow my faith in God if I'm
losing it please answer I really need to
know you know this is a question that to
me sounds like there's a lot of pain in
here how do I grow my faith in God I
think there are lots of things that we
call spiritual disciplines or things
that help us grow I think community is
one of them is church important maybe
the answer is community important and
the answer is yes so how do you grow
your faith in God sometimes it's gonna
be about being in community and if
you're losing it I think sometimes it's
okay to have those doubts and questions
and actually I think if you feel like
you're losing your faith it's a good
time to like question it the truth of
the matter is is any relationship even
with God is gonna have doubts and any
questions that you have
you know I know that somebody doesn't
really actually care about me if they
stop asking questions about me so if I
were if I really didn't care about you
by just you know I wouldn't ask more
questions of you I wouldn't question you
deeper who just be like you know a
relationship is kind of ending when you
no longer even have the desire to
disagree so I think it's okay to lose
some of your faith and pretty work and
change and maybe don't think of it as
losing it think of it as changing and
also big a lot of time why when we do
lose our faith is because we feel like
God is breaking themes from us mhm
but what I've come to discovery is every
time God breaks something off of us it's
not that he's actually breaking us he's
breaking the things that we don't need
to give this to the next level and each
time he breaks those things off of all
he's doing is placing rattlin and meet
us so what do that
he's elevating us to the next level so
Tong sometime when you're going through
the season where he losing you're
actually gaining because the Word of God
saying all things work together for the
good so how do you grow your faith you
understand that everything you lose is
it really a loss and sometimes you have
to go through those darkest moment yeah
I said let there be light and look what
he created
so after darkness can be something
wonderful waiting on the other side so
take those dark moments in your life
to actually see what he's trying to do
so when you come out that door place
when you come out that tunnel you will
see why you gotta be isolated and then I
don't know for someone I think - it's
like a lot of times people are afraid of
people having doubts and so you'll hear
pastors say you shouldn't doubt this is
true so they capital T but I think doubt
is actually necessary for faith I think
anyone who tells you that every day
every moment they be 100% and I just
don't think that's true and that's not
how we are we lead question and we want
to know everything we're curious about
me I think what you'll discover
sometimes is the more doubt you have
this this different sort of thing is
being born and you cam Spears ass is
having doubts okay and I think the
answer is not only is it okay but it's
absolutely necessary there's this
beautiful understanding if you're a
Christian we come out of the Jewish
tradition and in Judaism the
understanding is like Scripture is meant
to be argued with like Kim and I are
meant to have disagreements because
that's how we grow as we look at we read
together and we learn together it's
never meant to be in isolation and the
more and more I questioned this the more
and more I'm actually falling a little
bit different parts of it and there
sometimes I just want to throw the whole
thing out and I think if we're only
honest with everyone around us and say
like I have doubts
all the time I have belts about so much
I have I'm in a season right now in my
life who that's this Kim this is cam cam
excuse me I'm in the season right now in
my life where it's like God is this
really what you want me to do but you
know what God would do he'll blow your
mind and he socked me in this chair
right now to answer this Crescent for
you but it wasn't even really for you
this but my confirmation we all we all
have our
what we feel like you know we feel like
waving the flag where we feel like going
Italian doubts is a part of the human
nature we flesh and then we're spiritual
and if you don't have doubts your life
relationship - I think you know even
when you're talking if you're talking
about your friends you know the the idea
of like again I don't care about you if
I don't ask you what's up with you if I
don't question you if I don't all these
sort of things that's part of it right
all right so ezg says do you have to get
baptized to be saved the short answer to
that is no no mmm could you could be
laid on your bed of affliction or you
can be you know just got shopping just
ask lord please save me coming to my
life and save me and you you do just
that so I believe that be baptized
yeah and you know earlier the question
about the nominations a lot of that hell
says about how to be baptized some
people believe it your I had a good
friend in seminary whose church
rebaptised someone because when they
looked at the photo his pinky finger was
out of the water which meant his finger
was still not redeemed or saved and so
do they this is the pinky finger go to
hell and that was like it actually a
logical question I don't think you have
to be baptized to be saved because again
we talked about saved a little bit but
the idea that a baby mm-hmm their babies
that aren't baptized the ID all these
sort of things I think yeah it depends
on how you see God and for for me and
for how I feel I really don't think that
you have to be baptized I think it's
part of the journey alright so that was
easy G so the next question Falcons can
Christians go to hell I'll see ya how's
everybody walking for God isn't sincere
it's because you call yourself a car
don't mean you actually a car just
because you inside a garage and you say
oh I'm a car you got a car it's because
you say you a Christian are you really a
crispity you really have a relationship
with God I believe is going to be some
Christmas in a hill all right so
and this whole I remember we'll be
talking about how interesting because we
get this idea of how a lot of people
don't realize that most of the images
and stuff that we talk about in America
about health really are from Dante's
Inferno and are from different
understandings of hell that are actually
from from society they're not from
Scripture when we talk about some of the
scriptural or understandings of Hell
some of those come from the book of
Revelation which is interesting again as
the book of Revelation was written in
code they're in again an oppressed
people writing about it in the middle of
being oppressed so what do you do with
that well oftentimes they would write in
code and it's kind of like imagine is
you know thousand years from now people
looked at one of our magazines and they
saw that a donkey was fighting an
elephant they'd be like Oh donkeys and
elephants used to be President of the
United States instead of like looking at
so I can't I don't think you could take
revelation and the idea of hell to be
like exactly what we're told and by the
way I just believe it was today
I think there's hell I mean the way that
some people are living is hell so there
and by that I mean thank you lord
right and so um but I also believe in a
Living God and so when it comes to
deciding again it may feel wishy-washy
but the more and more time I spend in my
face and in study I really think we
don't always have the answers and
actually that's alright
and so hell for me I don't need help I
don't need help to exist my life is
really so much better by my ability to
lean into my faith and so for me I don't
need there to be a hill for me to be
good or do good it's more about kind of
the idea of how can I create heaven on
earth heaven present what is the kingdom
of God look like I know that's a really
long answer we could go on for hours all
right
therapy I suffered a miscarriage and my
fiancee and I weren't married is our
baby in heaven is it okay to be angry
with God about this loss why didn't he
allow it oh please again a lot of these
questions thank you for them because I
think they really are showing that
there's
pain and you're being vulnerable and I
appreciate that and so um why did you
suffer this miscarriage I don't think we
know the answer to that I don't think
it's because you're being punished
because your fiance and you weren't
married is your baby in heaven yep and I
think the Lord will show you as you seek
Him more and you pray he will show you
exactly why this had to take place I
believe everything is a learning curve
and I know this is something that's
devastated and I empathized which you
cannot feel your pain you and your
fiance but all things work together you
guys want to come out of come out of
this better and I believe that God will
place more inside your womb so you can
give birth to it is devastated I'm
hopeful that but I don't think that like
I you know I struggle with all things
work together for good I mean it is
Scripture but I think sometimes we say
that you know there's something Goods
gonna come out of this and truthfully we
say those kind of things sometimes even
as pastors when we don't know how to
answer your pain and so I'm in this
moment I'm gonna tell you that it's okay
to be angry with almost definitely but I
think you're gonna look back speaking
from a purse a person who actually knows
most people that this doesn't happen to
you know speaking from experience it
works how I look at it is gonna work out
you gonna be able to look back like man
that was painful but it taught me so
much then when you do have a child
you're able to say well God thank you
and you be able to cherish that baby
even more so I think you yeah I know and
even if we don't always know the reason
for things and I sometimes think there's
not a reason
then that right now you know this is not
the fulfillment of time I think
something else is coming and I think
that there is darkness and difficulty in
the world and so yeah all right so the
next questions are not max what are your
thoughts on them their name is not max
what are your thoughts on suicidal
tendencies and can you give me something
to help me overcome those tendencies max
max you are worth it you are worth it
being here in this world we need you
mm-hmm overcoming those tendencies is
probably going to take having some folks
in your life some professionals that can
help you for why you feel that way
whenever I've had to deal with suicide
in my own ministry whenever I've had to
deal with suicide in my home life with
friends the truth of the matter is when
you are feeling those things that's not
you that's a difficulty that's sometimes
we have this this fear and this thing
that we can't overcome that makes us
feel like the part of like we're in
right now it's gonna last forever and
it's a darkness and it's difficult and I
think the only way you can overcome
these things is by having other people
step in the light with you and so max I
would just ask not max you're not max oh
my you would find someone that you trust
and that you can share those thoughts
with and I think the the truth is is
we're not ourselves when we have to the
thoughts and feelings
it's a difficult time and I can't tell
you how many people I have had to sit in
a funeral in here the the truth of the
matter is when this person did take
their life it was because they weren't
being themselves and had they just been
given more time or whatever it might be
that that wouldn't have been their
choice and I think so many times I heard
stories of people and there's a great
the man that almost jumped over the San
Francisco where he did jump off the
bridge
and survived and he tells that he
regretted it and I think the truth is
things are hard and they're really hard
but they're not going to stay the same
and
it's gonna require you reaching out so
find somebody that you trust and even if
it's some of these friends that you have
online whatever it might be
make sure that you are getting not only
just support for professional help
because usually there is something going
on in our brains that lead us to go to
that your loved man totally what you
said your love your work that you're
here for a reason man you will be out of
this yes and you know oftentimes one of
my favorite things I love the idea that
we're all here for a reason and a
purpose and and I think we're actually
all here for reasons and purposes and I
think the truth is we need you on this
earth so stay around and things not mix
you've got it as now max mr. smiley
aesthetic says our demons real now
believe it or I believe we all babbling
with art with demons I believe suicide
is a demon you battled with that
so I most definitely do believe this
yeah again this is one of those things
where I look at what is it
what is a demon and you know I think
that demons really are those those
things those those things that we feel
like we're running away from you demons
are those moments when we feel like
we're tempted toward something
demons can be even the voices in our
head the demon yourself in the mirror
little running around even so I think
what he really wants to know is if we
think mr. smiley I'm guessing you're a
man but you can choose to self-identify
you know I believe we we battle with the
Prince of Darkness on yeah he the enemy
roar like a lion see me who we can
devour
I knew believe that Satan is to have his
people here that's trying to take it out
all right I have a different view of
that okay so the last question is how
did you find Jesus I didn't know he was
lost
discover Jesus why don't you go first
how did you find Jesus well always heard
my mother grandmothers my family
speaking of this guy just religion this
man named Jesus I will always see my
grandma praying when I was young and I
started to listen
start praying but I really didn't
experience anything alone I was just
praying because I knew that's what
grandma did but as I got older and like
to begin to happen and I began to go
through hell I began to lose things I
almost lost my mind I was depressed you
know that's when I was able to find if
we're gonna say I was able to find Jesus
and I was really able to accept him when
I was like at the Lord placed in my life
cuz I felt like I should have died you
know get shot at selling drugs doing all
these things and yet I didn't die
there's people that did the same exact
thing that I've done and they're gone
but God killed me and that's how I knew
right then and there
Jesus was real because mama could have
turned my life around
granny couldn't do it it passed we
couldn't do it couldn't nobody do this
but God and that's when I found I felt
that when I was at my most darkest place
um I think how did I find Jesus for me I
grew up in a home both my parents were
Christians but we didn't grow up in a
house that made us go to church or we
went to church but when I was 13 I got
confirmed in my tradition which is like
we are baptized as kids and then when
we're 13 or around those age we can
choose to do confirmation classes
Catholicism has something similar and I
remember the pastor saying like after
this point if your parents make you go
to church I'm gonna come and talk to
them because you shouldn't have to go to
church after you've made this decision
and it was the first time at 13 that
someone had said
this is up to you and I remember feeling
like huh
am I gonna decide if Jesus is real more
not for me and so I had this whole
conversation and I've had it several
times before where I talked to Jesus and
said like I've hardly stories of you and
I've discovered you and I grew up in a
culture that talks about you but I want
to know like who you are in in reality
what my life looks like I'm paid out and
played out and so for me it's just been
a it was a process over time you know a
lot of people have dramatic stories of
how they encountered Jesus but it's
always been those things t that I come
back to this story and even when
Christians let me down and Christianity
is not what I want it to be even being a
pastor is hard and sometimes people are
really difficult it's like the stories
that I keep coming back to you are the
stories of Jesus and who Jesus was and
so I feel like I continually find Jesus
and I'm you know I fall more and more in
love with the story and the person of
the story and I feel the presence of
Jesus and I just that's for me the way
that I found Jesus so we want to say a
huge thank you thank you yeah thank you
I talk to each other and figure this out
this is both of our various
livestreaming yes thank you
you survived it with us okay so how can
you how can you be found on social media
well my Instagram is at
ITSs revs:1773rpm I well I just want to
leave you guys with this whatever you're
going through you know it's is here to
bill you of man in life it can be rough
in life you can get to a place where you
don't want to even live but God and I
keep saying to God I've served we'll
pull you out of that dark moment there's
people on here who likes is gonna be
changed forever just by listening to
these answers that we was able to share
so I just want to encourage you to keep
the faith stay on stay on the wall keep
trust and if you
grow your relationship will get closer
here answer it doesn't matter what
position you in it doesn't matter what
you think you dumb you're never to four
from God's grace you're never to four
from his mercy he's right there just
called out answer every time say my
final side is something actually that
someone shared with me a long time ago
there is this story in the Bible about
when Jesus was being baptized and when
he's baptized there is this voice that
call that that says you are my son the
beloved with whom I'm well pleased and I
heard that story like so much and maybe
you've heard that story a lot but
something that a pastor pointed out to
me one time is that Jesus hadn't done
anything yet and so I want my final
thought for you to be that you are the
beloved with whom God is well pleased
and you haven't even done anything yet
and I think that our identity rests on
that is that you are loved and you are
loved
and you can find that in all kinds of
ways of places so thanks for spending
this time with us we have an amazing day
we share